nous en arrivons donc aux questions
orales et à la première question numéro
125 de Monsieur Jean-Pierre Chauveau à
Madame la Ministre de la réforme de
l'État de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
mon cher collègue merci monsieur le
Président Madame le ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur les appels de cotisation
de la médecine du travail pour les
collectivités territoriales en effet
toutes les connectivités territoriales
et les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale on sont
soumis à une stricte obligation de
versement de leurs cotisations le
montant de celle-ci est calculé en
fonction de l'effectif déclaré ce mode
de calcul serait bien compréhensible si
chacun des salariés était réellement
convoqués à une visite annuelle ou à une
visite Biennale
en principe ces visites périodiques ont
théoriquement lieu tous les 24 mois une
dérogation est même possible au delà de
deux ans sous réserve de l'obtention
d'un agrément du service de santé au
travail
cependant le paiement par les
collectivités restent annuelles et son
calcul se fait chaque année il existe un
réel décalage entre le principe et les
réalités ce décalage m'a été confirmé
par toutes les collectivités que j'ai pu
interroger ainsi pour prendre un exemple
la communauté de communes que je préside
seulement 20% des salariés sont en
moyenne examinés chaque année ce qui
fait une fois tous les 5 ans
en pratique on peut constater que les
services de la médecine du travail
examinent les salariés très au-delà de
la limite des deux ans bien sûr les
salariés peuvent toujours être examinés
à leur demande ma question n'a pour but
que de remettre en cause de n'a pas pour
but de remettre en cause le
fonctionnement de ce service ce qui
motive ma question est en réalité le
mode de calcul des cotisations
en effet au regard des visites Raymond
effectuées l'établissement d'un nouveau
mode de calcul pourrait permettre aux
collectivités locales et à leurs EPCI
d'échapper à des dépenses indus
concrètement aujourd'hui compte tenu des
sommes versées une visite médicale
périodique et effectuée réalisée coûte
aux alentours de 500 euros par personne
par agent par ailleurs en Sarthe santé
au travail c'est visites ne sont plus
effectuées par des médecins mais par des
infirmières spécialisés
aussi je souhaiterais savoir si le
gouvernement envisage d'établir un
nouveau mode de calcul celui-ci pourrait
s'établir en fonction de la réalité du
service rendu ce qui me semblerait tout
à fait logique il ne s'agit pas de
réduire le financement des services de
la médecine du travail mais plutôt de le
moderniser pour permettre un paiement à
l'acte c'est très forme permettrait aux
collectivités d'économiser la moitié de
leurs dépenses liée aux visites
périodiques et qui ne sont pas réalisés
je ne souhaite pas ouvrir une polémique
mais trouver avec pragmatisme dans ce
domaine des pistes pour faire des
économies par avance madame le ministre
je vous remercie de votre réponse merci
mon cher collègue la parole est à madame
Anne-Marie Escoffier mini chargée de la
décentralisation merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur chevaux
madame Marylise le branchu aurait
souhaité être là pour répondre plus
précisément peut-être que moi encore à
la question que vous venez de poser mais
elle est retenue ce matin par
l'ouverture des négociations syndicales
dans le cadre de la fonction donc elle
m'a chargé de répondre à cette question
vous l'avez dit votre objectif c'est pas
du tout de modifier le contexte dans
lequel la médecine du travail et la
médecine préventive est organisée une
médecine préventive qui est organisée
dès lors que la loi de 84 l'a prévu avec
son décret d'application du 10 juin 85
vous savez que normalement chaque
collectivité est tenue d'organiser un
service de médecine préventive qu'ils
peuvent créer ou adhérer à un service
commun en fait il y a trois possibilités
au moins la première c'est de faire
appel à un service de santé au travail
régie par le titre 2 du livre 6 de la
quatrième partie du code du travail
service de médecine inter-entreprise ou
service de santé au travail du secteur
agricole c'est la première possibilité
la deuxième et qui se développe beaucoup
sur nos territoires c'est de faire appel
à ses à ses associations
le but non lucratif qui se sont créés
justement pour répondre à cette
obligation de médecine du travail et
enfin ce sont les conditions
conventionnelles soit par le versement
d'une cotisation additionnelle à la
cotisation obligatoire due au centre de
gestion soit à la possibilité de
disposer d'un service de médecine
préventive qui existe au centre même je
le rappelle simplement mais je voudrais
aussi rappeler la difficulté dans
laquelle aujourd'hui se trouve la France
pour avoir des médecins de médecine du
travail vous savez que c'est une des
spécialités qui est les plus difficiles
et on manque cruellement de ces médecins
de médecine du travail or les médecins
de médecine du travail ont deux missions
ils ont une mission de santé plus de
santé
une mission de santé en milieu de
travail et une mission de médecine
préventive la mission de médecine
préventive ne porte que sur un tiers du
temps d'activité de ces médecins un
tiers ou un peu plus et donc il y a un
partage ce qui fait que effectivement
comme vous l'avez relevé nos
fonctionnaires ne bénéficient pas d'un
contrôle tous les ans mais comme vous le
dites 20 % d'entre eux et au mieux tous
les deux ou les trois ans alors que la
cotisation elle est calculée chaque
année cependant on ne peut pas
déterminer exactement ce que sera la
part de ces contrôles au titre de la
mission de travail Santé Travail est-ce
que sera la part consacré à la médecine
préventive dès lors aujourd'hui on en
reste sur cette cotisation au forfait
c'est un point que Madame le branchu a
examiné qu'elle continuera d'examiner
avec l'ensemble de ses partenaires dans
les meilleures conditions possibles pour
mieux répondre à vos attentes mais je
dois dire que aujourd'hui sa
préoccupation ne l'amène pas à
privilégier un changement de la lég
islation et de la réglementation en
cours
merci madame la ministre monsieur
Chauveau
oui juste un mot pour remercier Madame
la Ministre effectivement il faudrait
qu'on arrive à trouver une solution
notamment dans les trois pistes entre
autres que vous avez soulevées bon mais
je dois dire que l'idéal ça serait quand
même qu'on est une adéquation un petit
peu entre d'un côté les services rendus
et d'un autre côté
le paiement que réalise le collectivité
à une époque à un moment où on cherche
partout les moyens
à serrer au maximum nos budgets ça me
semble pas tout à fait logique et donc
il faut aller il faut qu'on essaie de
trouver des solutions qui soient mieux
adaptées à la réalité merci